can we come back to masculinity yeah
please because I think this is very
interesting uh I was once at a dinner uh
small dinner was about TW 12 of us maybe
with Jordan Peterson uh and I asked him
what western civilization is and Jordan
in as is his style went off on a 20
minute thing and I was like I have no
idea where you're going Jordan
right but what he said was very
interesting he said that he talked about
how in chimp
groups the alpha male is often one of
the smallest males in other words it's
not a Joo willnick it's me or I mean
you're bigger than me but you know it's
one of us and the reason for that is
that the alpha male strategy the pub
brawler strategy in groups does not work
very well for very long you are only on
top as long as you are physically the
strongest male in that group uh and and
when two or more smaller chimps can get
together and kill you they
will the difference with chimp groups is
that the reason the smaller males are
often the alpha male is that they're
very good at building
coalitions and so to me masculinity
isn't about having big muscles or having
a big head or wide fists or whatever uh
if we think about our conversation
earlier about power like I remember
talking to Ben Shapiro about this and he
was like yeah there's this guy on the
internet who's like yeah I could I could
take I've got big muscle and she like
yeah I could pay people to shoot you
that's the Coalition thing right power
isn't projected through your fist in the
modern world is projected through the
power that you have over other people as
a leader so to me uh being hyper
masculine is not about having big
muscles or having a big head um it's
about your ability to project power and
authority what kind of leader are you uh
and you know you mentioned other stuff
like your level of aggression and all
these all these other things so I think
defining masculinity is simply a
physical thing is is very
narrow if you had to put people on a
spectrum MH of masculine mhm who pegs
out the meter is it Joo willink or is it
Ben Shapiro that's probably terrible
because jao can build coalitions is it
um what's his name the The Fighter the
boxer he has a show called The Gypsy
King otherwise I would not Tyson Fury
Tyson Fury or Ben Shapiro who maxes out
the masculinity meter H that's
interesting I I I think I suspect on
that level of analysis everybody would
say Tyson Fury yes I would you would
however the the the question for me is
um the definition is what predetermines
the outcome right um I that's so
important yeah holy I hope people
pull that out yeah well how you define
masculinity automatically defines who
you think is
masculine and the question for me me is
what which of those options would I like
to be I could go to the gym and become
really big and strong I could do and I
did it for a while didn't wasn't
particularly my thing I didn't enjoy it
I like being in shape I don't like
having you know going to the gym and
lifting lots of way get didn't work for
me and the level of power that that
gives you over the power in a healthy
sense influence over the world being
able to manifest the things that you
want Etc is
minuscule compared to the power that you
have by building groups of people who
follow you into whatever battle or
project or whatever it is you want to do
um and then there's the family aspect
how do you treat the women and children
in your life to me healthy masculinity
is a lot about that actually so when I
see some guy with his shirt off in big
muscles talking about how he you know
he's got 10 hoes or whatever I I don't I
don't really see that as healthy
masculinity agreed some people might do
and I'm sure the gasan model which is
basically that some people would say
well that's you know biologically that
is hyper masculinity because like half
the world or whatever is descended from
him that would have been a great example
genas Khan not gigantic but is he hyper
masculine yeah I would say so to me like
in fact he pegs the meter right
kill them all no problem just we're
taking over we run this now yeah
and actually if you look historically a
lot of the leaders who really made a
huge impact on human society they've all
been very small Napoleon Hitler Stalin
wasn't a big guy
Putin you think that plays into it
because I could see very easily how of
course it does like oh you think I'm not
powerful because I'm smaller than you I
will show you I want to go back speaking
of that to Alpha versus beta so I think
we have a delusional sense of what an
alpha male is I saw a documentary I used
to think an alpha male would be Tyson
Fury not I don't know him he could be
the smartest guy on planet Earth uh but
the sort of once removed thought of him
as as a fighter a big physically
intimidating Fighter
um I saw a documentary about wolves and
I was shocked shocked I say when I saw
that the alpha male was small and I was
like I'm sorry what and what I realized
in that moment was the Alpha's the
decision maker the alpha is the
Coalition Builder the alpha is the one
that can think because again in in the
marketplace of we are wolves and if we
don't take down that Caribou we
die all of a sudden you go yeah bro that
guy I don't know how but he knows where
to go and he knows where to be and he
gives me the look at just the right
moment and when I follow him I eat and
when I don't I don't and so what ends up
happening often times is the alpha male
is small but sharp and the beta
male which in our society has gotten a
terrible rap is the
enforcer and it was watching that
documentary was so unreal so you've got
a pack of whatever six wolves Alpha kind
of small beta the biggest and when they
all went for the kill the um beta mail
came and told everyone to off
growled backed everybody down so the
alpha could eat the liver and I was like
holy he's not even doing it for
himself he's well I mean he is he's
protecting the alpha to make sure that
the right person to make the decisions
and all of that that can keep the group
together whatever whatever is well taken
care of wellfed and has what he needs so
that really got me thinking so yes while
I agree with you that the person who's
going to have the outsized impact isn't
necessarily going to be what I will call
quote unquote the most masculine because
again all of us are 120 sided dice
rolled and so like hey maybe I'm as
smart as gask Khan was but I'm not
vicious like that like I just dude like
when I think about people getting
stabbed or I'm just like oh God like
clearly I'm not going to be the guy that
goes and takes over the planet uh that
just I'm way too screamish for that
so when I think
about the thinking of something on a
simplistic scale is probably the flaw in
my thinking and that it's really a far
more dimensional three dimensions if we
want to go all the way to four it's like
you've got a tesseract of traits that
makes for masculine feminine whatever
which I think leads to also some of the
debate because it really is such a
complex topic if somebody can give you a
hyper simplified version I say I'm Stacy
therefore I'm Stacy it's it has a lot of
gravitational pole because it simplifies
a very complicated idea and sticking
with the alpha conversation who who was
the alpha Michael Jordan or Scotti
Pippen Scotty Pippen's a lot taller a
lot bigger yeah who was Alpha Kobe O
Shack that's a good one
right what's really interesting in that
one is they were both Alpha and that was
the problem that's why they collided
they couldn't neither could defer to the
other yes if Shaq had been the enforcer
they probably would have won 20
championships right exactly um but I
think ultimately Kobe was the alpha in
that situation and Shaq eventually you
know same with the there lots of
situations like that look at that level
they're all Alphas but someone's got to
be the alpha in that particular group
yeah that's interesting and how fast
that happens when you've been the best
ball player in your every team your
middle school team your high school team
your college team and then you get to
the NBA and you're like oh I'm like
seventh or eighth in the pecking order
it becomes a real question about can you
become a ro a role player yeah it's
exactly right and I forget who it was in
um I think it was 11 rings by Phil
Jackson and Phil I know you listen to
this show God I wish I doubt it very
much I so want to get him on